these allegations that i have sent  inappropriate pictures  over the internet are completely  ridiculous these allegations are false  and i will be vindicated  tmz has obtained an actual photo of your  genitalia they're posting it to their  website as we speak they're saying you  took it how do you respond  okay i may have sent one photo of my  genitalia all right okay  that's an isolated it was a one-time  thing  senator what about the new report that  there are three new pictures having been  sent to three different women  what second-rate news organization  is trying to new york times  okay it was it was four total no more  that was it it was just four there was  four and no more  yes amy yes you are sure that there were  only four photos sent that's it four  then how do you explain the one you sent  me